probably the biggest
unexpected news story that is taking
people's attention right now really
awful awful story there is a submersible
it's not quite a submarine exactly it's
a submersible
device that is carrying five people
somewhere in deep sea in the middle of
the Atlantic Ocean they were on a trip
to go look at the Titanic and the
company lost contact with the
submersible pretty quickly and now
they're running out of air or the US
government's involved trying to recover
this but you know they're looking at a
search area the size of the state of
Connecticut and the submersible is not
very big it's pretty cramped and so it's
it's just about as horrifying a story as
one could imagine in terms of ways to go
just in a cramped little Tin Can at the
bottom of the Atlantic ocean near the
Titanic that's pretty terrifying where
you don't know
we don't really know what's happened to
these people there's a chance they're
already dead and the way they would have
died is uh if the somehow the cabin
became depressurized and then the weight
of the ocean would have just crushed it
all up that would have been very quick
or they could just be waiting somewhere
with waiting for the oxygen to run out
which apparently is going to happen or
may have already happened by 5 00 a.m
eastern time
um
or
it might take months and months to find
this submersible or we might never find
this inversible uh
people are criticizing the company right
now because the company seems to have
cut some corners on safety and seems to
have gone a little bit woke and said
they wouldn't hire old white guys
because that's not inspiring enough or
something here's here's some audio of
the head of the company
when I started the business one of the
things you'll find there are other
sub-operators out there but they they
typically
um have a gentleman who are ex-military
submariners and they you'll see a whole
bunch of 50 year old white guys I wanted
our team to be younger to be
inspirational and I'm not going to
inspire a 16 year old to to go pursue
Marine technology but a 25 year old uh
you know who's a subpilot or a platform
operator or one of our techs can be
inspirational so we've really tried to
to get
um very intelligent motivated younger
individuals involved because we're doing
things that are completely new we're
taking approaches that are used largely
in the Aerospace industry is related to
safety and uh some of the profoundness
of checklists things we do for risk
assessments and things like that that
are more Aviation related than ocean
related and we can train people to do
that we can train someone to Pilot the
sub we use a game controller um so
anybody can drive the sub
so they use a game controller they've
used all this new kind of Technology
they've applied aviation technology to
the sub the critics are saying you cut
too many corners this was insane why on
Earth would anyone get into this thing
the Defenders of this are saying well
this is the Explorer spirit this is
Adventure this is a great we shouldn't
discourage this of course you got to be
a little bit crazy to go explore parts
of the world and that's a good thing and
we should encourage it
the people knew the risks that that
seems to be certain there's a 61 year
old British digital marketing magnet
named Chris Brown he had put a deposit
down to go on on a voyage on this
submersible and then he backed out at
the last minute because he said the
risks are too high he said the risks
were too high in this instance even
though I'm not one to shy away from risk
and he was buddies with a billionaire
Hamish Harding who is down there in the
submersible and Harding said okay well
I'm willing to accept the risk
there's a teenager also with his father
that's especially sad but but people at
least knew this was a risky thing and
they decided to do it anyway right now
go to cinch.com use promo code Knowles
picture picture it the perfect Summer
Night the warm breeze just gently
lapping your face as you Lounge in your
favorite chair outside the grill
sizzling with Juicy gooey Burgers the
aroma of the food it's irresistible boy
I need a hot shower after this or a cold
shower I guess well now imagine
what this perfect summer night would
look like if you went to turn on the
grill and your propane tank were empty
that's where our friends at cinch come
in cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule and requires
no long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere whether you're grilling steaks
or lighting up the patio heaters on a
cold night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment
go to cinch.com or download the synch
app to order new customers can get their
first tank exchanges for just 10 bucks
with promo code Knolls that's cinch.com
or download the Cinch app use promo code
nulls to get your first tank exchange
for just ten dollars this is a limited
time offer you must live with an
essential service area to redeem it go
to cinch.com offer for details right now
text nulls to 98 98.98 Congress once
again allowed itself to be pushed into a
piecing the administration and raising
the debt ceiling for the 79th time
Paving the way for continued Reckless
spending and further devaluation of the
dollar as our national debt continues to
Skyrocket how are you protecting your
savings Times Like These are a great
reminder to diversify a portion of your
savings into gold and you can do that
with the help of Birch gold Birch gold
will help you convert an existing Ira or
401K into an IRA in Gold you don't pay a
penny out of pocket when currencies fail
gold is a safe haven how much more time
does the Dollar have protect your
savings with gold Birch gold has an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers text
Knowles kwels to 98 98 98 it's your free
info kit on gold text Knowles kwles to
98 98 98
I am not on either side of the internet
debate over the
wisdom or idiocy of getting in this sub
Mar defending the adventure Spirit some
are criticizing the recklessness I think
that Prudence is called for here
I don't think that the proper response
to this is either condemnation or
valorization of what they're doing I
think the prop and some people are
making jokes about it and posting memes
and it's really sad I mean these are
human beings who are either dead or
could very soon die
I think the proper response is prayer
for the people and also prayer for the
wisdom to make these kinds of judgments
I am not of the opinion that it's always
a great and wonderful thing to go climb
Mount Everest
I don't I don't think that's dreading
sometimes it can be Reckless and
suicidal and deeply dark and sinister
and I'm also not of the opinion that
it's always a terrible thing to go climb
Mount Everest
that you should just stay in your home
and always make the safe Choice I'm not
of that opinion either
it's a little bit more complicated
you've got to use your prudence and your
judgment and and calculate risks and
weigh risks and see what's to be gained
here some of the people criticizing uh
this company or saying well this you
weren't exploring anything new you were
just going down to a shipwreck that's
one of the most studied shipwrecks ever
so this was just tourism and it was
tourism that cut a lot of corners and
was very very expensive but I don't know
on the other hand as far as tourism goes
it's pretty pretty adventurous it seems
to me and and so I just think when we
make these decisions on on all political
matters
we are especially in the digital age
where we're addicted to extremism and
clicks we we just want to be able to say
okay here is the solution it's always
good to go do the extremely dangerous
thing or no this is never good this is
dumb and this is stupid and we should
mock these people and I know a lot more
about submarines than this company
doesn't but that isn't the case you see
it on speech say we need absolute Free
Speech or some people say no we need to
strongly censor the conservatives what
if
what if there is a moderate middle
ground that takes into account
all of these kinds of ideas and then
exercises Prudence moderation is a
virtue I consider myself very moderate I
know the libs think that I'm to the
right of Genghis Khan but I can say I'm
a very moderate person you know what a
great video that was huh make sure you
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel ring that Bell we'll see you
next time